hi guys I'm Erik Bosse and Avengers
infinity Wars game-changing villain
Thanos has a new origin story created
specific to the Marvel Cinematic
Universe
look at us comic nerds thinking we know
a guy and then Kevin Feige drops in and
says look at this man he is not who you
think he is
don't judge a Grape Ape by its color
though I'm gonna explain what this new
origin story is how it's different from
the comics and how it connects to what
we already know about Thanos and make
some theories about what it could mean
for infinity war and be a spoiler
warning in case I get any of this stuff
right so here's what we know in a recent
article in Entertainment Weekly Marvel
Studios head Kevin Feige revealed this
about the MCU version of Thanos being
played by Josh Brolin he's from a planet
called Titan that's no longer inhabited
because of things that he thought he
could help prevent and he was not
allowed to do that what he feared most
happened and the planet and everybody on
it basically went extinct he vowed not
to let it happened again he thinks he
sees the universe going down the tubes
and he thinks he sees life expanding
outward unchecked that will bring ruin
he believes to the universe into that
light Feige characterized Thanos as a
glass-half-full guy wanting to save one
half of the universe by killing off the
other half he added that's either genius
or horrific depending on your point of
view and most of our point of view say
it's pretty terrific and then Josh
Brolin added all the kind of grabbing of
the moon because the gems and all that's
the fun stuff kind of keep Thanos
scented vegan Brolin is referring to
this epic image released with the
article showing demos using the Infinity
Gauntlet to grab hold of a nearby moon
and you know spike it down on the
surface which we now know is the ruins
of his homeworld tighten it so Feige and
Brolin are casting Thanos says a more
sympathetic figure an outsider on his
home world whose warnings were ignored
leading to catastrophe and extinction
now making it his mission to contain the
universe's chaotic population growth
saving the good half by wiping out the
bad half and unfortunately we are just
in the bathhouse now in the Infinity
Gauntlet storyline in the comics Thanos
his reasons aren't so noble he wipes out
half the universe just to impress the
cosmic entity mistress death he
basically becomes a god - woowoo God
another comic miniseries Thanos rising
established his Thanos his origin as a
young eternal with freakish purple skin
making him an outcast his mother
actually one of him killed immediately
despite growing up as a loner and a
pacifist various tragedies occur
involving lizards eating his friends and
all these events turn him into a cynic
and a vengeful killer leading him on a
psychotic killing spree that it's
implied wiped out his entire fellow race
of Eternals his storylines pretty good
at humanizing Thanos giving him
dimension beyond you know an evil war
mongering tyrant and I think Marvel
Studios is taking that humanization a
step further with this movie explaining
why the mad Titan is so mad for now at
least it's suggesting that they dose is
more a victim of cosmic violence than he
is in the comics but wouldn't surprise
me if it's revealed that he did it and
love affair with mr. steth is enough of
a back story in the comics not fun
enough because comics kind of wait
but in the movies if purple Josh Brolin
started reading bad poetry he wrote in
his diary about some space death goddess
played by Helen Mirren or something a
ton of viewers would be like yeah too
much not us of course we'd love that but
you know they gotta make these movies
where everyone and or Chinle and judging
for Brolin's own words Thanos will still
bring some of that fun there's the moon
toss Sun and there was his line in the
trailer as long as there's something one
considers the balance of universe
[Applause]
[Music]
oh I heard of chuckle in there now sure
that smile he referred to wasn't
probably as white as the one that he let
loose in the Avengers post-credit scene
when the idea of courting death came up
but I still expect baños to show
occasional flashes of humor the way Loki
and Ultron did the difference being that
sounds like Thanos's objectives are like
clear we've been hearing about for years
all of these previous MCU team ups have
really been leading up to thinness
taking the ball here
loki was doing his bidding and Avengers
and we learned that he was using Thanos
mind stone in the scepter and age of
Ultron Ronan's pursue to the Power Stone
and guardians of the galaxy was at the
behest of Thanos initially and civil war
was all about splitting up the Avengers
to make them more vulnerable when Tanis
would inevitably arrive and I think
establishing Thanos's perspective as
that of a savior in his own head is
meant to underline the folly of the
Avengers as heroes for a superhero to
win over and over again without truly
being tested or being forced to
reconsider their existence it leads to
their power just growing unchecked and
absolute power corrupts absolutely a
good super villain throws that back in
the hero's face testing him or her by
truly raising the stakes
so after Tony Stark and the others have
smugly come out on top so many times we
need a villain with a solid rationale to
show up and say hey your years of
tinkering have essentially made you a
god and if you want that power you're
gonna have to do what I did watch your
home world burn so what does that mean
for the MCU yeah it's a day of reckoning
heroes will die pacifically I think mr.
stark is done and really the only way
fans will accept something that tragic
is at the hands of a villain with an
origin story as compelling as his is but
it's a pretty big assumption that will
be the case not necessarily guaranteed
of course but if it is true I want to
throw this over to you guys
what's scenario would you see as the
most noble way to die for Tony Stark or
any of the Avengers an example offer out
there what if stark sacrifices himself
to save someone like Peter Parker to
take over the whole of injures franchise
comment down below to let me know your
thoughts or tweet me directly at EMS and
follow the new rockstars on Twitter for
updates on our videos like this video
and subscribe to
saris for breakdowns and theories on
everything related to Avengers infinity
war I can't wait for this movie thanks
for watching guys see you next time bye